DAY.
NOW WE HEAD TO THE STATE OF
NORTH CAROLINA WHERE REPUBLICANS
ARE STANDING STRONG AND TED BUDD
CONTINUES TO EXPOSE THE
RADICALISM OF FAR LEFT
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENT CHERI
BEASLEY.
HE HAS A 4.5% LEAD.
HERE WITH THE LATEST IN
NORTH CAROLINA, TED BUDD.
HE BROUGHT ALONG HIS FELLOW
CAROLYNIAN, LINDSEY GRAHAM IS
WITH YOU.
WELCOME BOTH OF YOU.
TED, YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO BUILD
UP A LEAD.
IT'S GONE FROM ONE POINT TO TWO
POINTS, NOW 4 1/2 POINTS.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
NORTH CAROLINA THAT IS BRINGING
YOU MORE SUPPORT ALMOST ON A
WEEKLY BASIS IN.
>> SEAN, THANKS FOR HAVING US.
WE'RE ALL CAROLINIANS TODAY.
THIS IS ABOUT INFLATION, CRIME
AND EDUCATION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE THINGS
THAT THE VOTERS WANT TO GET
BETTER IN THEIR LIFE.
EVERYTHING THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING IS MAKING IT WORSE.
EVERYTHING I'M DOING IS MAKING
LIFE BETTER FOR NOT JUST HERE IN
NORTH CAROLINA AND
SOUTH CAROLINA BUT THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
AND BEASLEY IS RUNNING FROM HER
RECORD.
SHE'S DEFENDED COP KILLERS,
THROWN OUT DIAMONDS FOR SEX
OFFENDERS.
THE MORE WE DIG INTO HER RECORD
THE WORSE IT GETS.
I'M FOR GETTING PARENTS A SAY IN
THEIR EDUCATION.
WE CAN'T LET UP IN THE NEXT 11
DAYS.
THAT'S WHY I HELP EVERYBODY GOES
TO TEDBUDD.COM AND FIGURE OUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE TECH BILLIONAIRES
BUT WE HAVE YOU AND YOUR VIEWERS
ON OUR SIDE.
WE NEED HELP.
>> Sean: LINDSEY, USED TO BE
DEMOCRATS WOULD HIDE THEIR
RADICALISM.
TRY TO RUN AS MODERATES.
THEY'RE NOT HIDING IT ANYMORE.
YOU KNOW, THE ISSUES COME DOWN
TO RADICAL POLICIES ON ENERGY,
WIDE OPEN BORDERS.
DEFUND, DISMANTLE.
IT COMES DOWN TO WOKE EDUCATION
VERSUS TRADITIONAL CURRICULUM IN
SCHOOLS.
THEY'RE SAYING IT OPENLY AND NO
RESTRICTIONS AT ALL ON ABORTION.
THEY ALL SEEM TO BE OUT
RADICALING EACH OTHER THINKING
THAT WILL RESONATE WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF TWO YEARS
OF BIDEN?
>> THEY'RE IN A BIND HERE IF
THEY DON'T SAY THE THINGS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, NOBODY GIVES THEM
MONEY.
JUST LISTEN TO WHAT TED SAID
ABOUT MRS. BEASLEY.
SHE RAN STATEWIDE AND LOST BY
400 VOTES.
TRUMP WON BY LESS THAN 1
PERCENTAGE POINTS.
TED IS RUNNING ONE OF THE BEST
RACES IN THE COUNTRY.
DON'T LET THE POLLS FOOL YOU.
THESE PEOPLE SURGE AT THE RIGHT
TIME.
IF THEY SAY NO TO D.C.
STATEHOOD, IS A KNOW TO TRYING
TO SECURE THE BORDER, THEY'LL
LOSE ALL OF THE MONEY.
SO SHE RAISED $13 MILLION IN THE
LAST QUARTER.
TED RAISED 4.
FROM OCTOBER 1 TO OCTOBER 19,
THE LAST RECORDING PERIOD, SHE
RAISED 5.
TED RAISED 1 1/2.
YOUR AUDIENCE HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY GENEROUS.
TEDBUDD.COM.
11 DAYS LEFT.
EVERYTHING HE SAID NEEDS TO BE
IN A COMMERCIAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS MONEY
COMES FROM, SEAN.
>> Sean: I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU,
LINDSEY, THIS IS EVERY SINGLE
STATE, EVERY RACE, GUBERNATORIAL
RACE, SENATORIAL RACE.
WHERE ARE THEY GETTING THE TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM?
HAS ANYBODY LOOKED INTO IT?
>> I SURE WILL.
I DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS LEGIT ON
THE UP AND UP.
I DO KNOW THIS.
THE MONEY IS REAL.
13 TO 4.
HE'S BEING OUTRAISED 4 TO 1.
HEY HAS THE BEST STORY.
THERE'S A HEAD WIND FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THE NEXT 11 DAYS, TEDBUDD.COM.
IF HE CAN GET THE MONEY HE
NEEDS.
YOU HAVE HELPED HERSCHEL THREE
NIGHTS AGO.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOUR
AUDIENCE DID FOR HIM.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING
POUNDED.
LET'S CLOSE WITH A FLOURISH.
EVERY LIBERAL IS TRYING TO TAKE
OVER GEORGIA, NORTH CAROLINA AND
FLORIDA.
I LIVE NEAR THESE FOLKS.
WE NEED CONSERVATIVES TO HEAD
J.D.
THIS GUY HAS RUN THE BEST RACE
MAYBE IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
HE'S LEADING IN A STATE WHERE
IT'S HARD TO LEAD.
TEDBUDD.COM.
PRAY, VOTE AND GIVE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO STAY HUMBLE
AND WORK HARD.
GO THE NEXT 11 DAYS AND WIN
THIS.
WE NEED YOUR HELP